Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. In Argentinien steigt ein Spiel der besonderen Güte Klasse, der Superklassikon, das auch noch im Finale der Copa Libertadores. Wie es dazu kommen konnte und was das mit dem Land macht, das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit Andreas Geipel. Andreas, sei mir sehr herzlich willkommen.
Ja, hallo Max.
Sehr schön, dass du dich bereit erklärt hast, hier mir ein bisschen was zum Superklassikon zu erzählen, dessen Rückspiel jetzt dann am Wochenende steigt. Du hast einen besonderen Bezug zum argentinischen Fußball. Unter anderem bin ich auf dich aufmerksam geworden über die Webseite archifootball.com. Passiert denn da eigentlich noch was? Die Artikel sind ja alle ein bisschen älter. Erzähl mal so ein bisschen, was ihr da gemacht habt, vor allem früher.
Genau, also die Artikel sind tatsächlich schon etwas eingerostet. Allerdings nutzen wir immer noch die Plattform Facebook, um über den argentinischen Fußball zu berichten oder irgendwelche lustigen Anekdoten, die Meisterschaft, den deutschen Lesern ein bisschen aufzubereiten. Aber tatsächlich, den Blog gibt es an sich so nicht mehr. Aber wir haben uns halt gedacht, da sind viele alte, schöne Artikel dabei. Auch gerade die Rubrik Fan-Gesänge ist, glaube ich, sehr interessant für jeden Fußballfan. Deswegen ist die Seite immer noch online, aber wird tatsächlich –ich weiß nicht, der letzte Artikel muss –du hast es vielleicht besser gesehen –wahrscheinlich schon drei Jahre her sein.
Ja, ja, 2015, genau.
Genau, und ja, das ist halt nur ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Wir waren anfangs mal vier Autoren und dann sind nach und nach Leute abgesprungen und ja, du weißt es ja selbst, bei so kleinen Blogs bzw. unser Fokus liegt ja eigentlich zu 100 Prozent auf argentinischem Fußball und da hast du natürlich in Deutschland jetzt nicht so viele Leser oder Leute, die sich dafür interessieren und dementsprechend hast du halt immer für eine sehr kleine Gruppe sehr aufwendig die Saison oder irgendwelche Mannschaftenspieler aufgearbeitet und ja, in irgendeinem Fall mal, keine Ahnung, dann geht das Leben weiter, es stellt dir neue Aufgaben und Herausforderungen und dann musst du irgendwann mal vielleicht das eine oder andere Herzensprojekt ein bisschen, ja, nicht wegkicken, aber schleisen lassen, reduzieren oder zurückfahren. Und da ist halt einfach Facebook vom Format her oder auch Twitter ein bisschen einfacher, nicht so zeitaufwendig.
Das heißt aber quasi, dass wenn Hörerinnen und Hörern nach dieser Folge sich für den argentinischen Fußball interessieren, dann sollten sie euch am besten bei Facebook folgen.
Genau, da posten wir noch regelmäßig. Vielleicht nicht jeden Tag kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, aber alle paar Tage mal, wenn was passiert, ist es dort nachzulesen. Da kann man dabei bleiben auf jeden Fall. Das Schöne an Argentinien –ich spange jetzt mal schnell den Bogen –dass da ja sehr viel immer möglich ist, in jeglicher Hinsicht, ob das jetzt eine spannende Meisterschaft ist oder irgendwelche Geschichten rund um Clubs oder Vereine oder Spiele. Da könnte man sowas auch hauptberuflich machen, so wie in Argentinien beispielsweise ja jeden Tag eine Fußballzeitschrift rauskommt, wie der Kicker, so in dieser Stärke der Donnerstags-Ausgabe. Das gibt es da jeden Tag, also so 30 Seiten, nur Fußball. Das machen die voll, die Leute lesen das und kaufen das. Das kannst du natürlich auch machen, weil der Fußball dort einfach tausend Geschichten erzählt. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das in Europa nicht so der Fall ist, aber ich glaube, der europäische Fußball krankt ja schon. Du hast ja letzte Woche auch das Thema gehabt, der Weltfußball. Aber wir haben ja in Europa schon ein bisschen das Problem, dass die Meisterschaften teilweise ein bisschen langweilig sind in vielen Ländern.
Ja, das merken wir auch gerade hier im Kurzpass immer wieder gerne, wenn wir nach England, Spanien, Frankreich oder Italien gucken. Gerade in Deutschland ist es jetzt mal ein bisschen spannend. Hey, da freuen wir uns alle. Aber sag mal, wie kommt denn, dass du dich für den argentinischen Fußball interessierst?
Ja, das ist schon eine Leidenschaft, die ich ja schon viele Jahre habe. Ich war erstmals in Argentinien. Das war –kurz überlegen, wann war das überhaupt? 2003, glaube ich. 2003, 2004. Und da war ich dann drei, vier Monate in Buenos Aires. Und ab damals auch mein erstes Spiel war in der Bomboneda, also im Stadion von Boca Juniors gewesen. Damals ein Rückspieler Copa Südamerikaner gegen eine bolivianische Mannschaft. Und das war zeitgleich auch das letzte Spiel von Calitos Tevez, dem jungen Calitos, der damals auch unglaublich gespielt hat. Und irgendwie diese Zeit in Argentinien, die hatte mir damals so gut gefallen, dass ich dann nach meinem Studium, ich bin dann zurück nach Deutschland, hab zu Ende studiert quasi und bin danach, an einem Freitag mein Diplom bekommen und am Montag One Way nach Buenos Aires geflogen und dann dort drei Jahre geblieben. Und seit 2011 sind wir wieder, so meine Frau und ich, sind wieder zurück in Deutschland und in Berlin. Aber dieser Kontakt und die Leidenschaft zu Argentinien und dem Fußball ist nie abgebrochen. Und ich versuche halt eigentlich so einmal im Jahr, wenn es geht, dass ich runterfliege.
Die Bombonera, die ist ja wahrscheinlich vielen Hörern und Hörern ein Begriff. Boca, vielleicht auch der bekannteste Verein aus Buenos Aires. Maradona, großer Edelfan. Kann man da noch edel sagen? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber führ uns mal so ein bisschen ein. Du hast schon gesagt, im argentinischen Fußball passiert so viel, dass man da jeden Tag ganz, ganz viele Seiten füllen könnte. Was macht denn den argentinischen Fußball aus? Es gibt viel drum herum. Es gibt Geschichten jeglicher Couleur, also sowohl positive, wie auch negative, auch Geweihe zwischen Fanszenen. Spielt da eine Rolle? Werden wir gleich auch noch mal ein bisschen darüber sprechen müssen, wahrscheinlich, vor diesem Rückspiel. Aber wie würdest du den argentinischen Fußball jemanden beschreiben, der bisher damit noch nicht zu vielen Berührungen kam?
Ich würde sagen total heiß, leidenschaftlich, übertrieben, total losgelöst und super frenetisch. Es gibt keinen Grau, es gibt nur Schwarz oder Weiß. Also nur gewinnen oder verlieren. Eine unglaubliche Stimmung im Stadion. Also ich denke gerade, wenn man dann doch –Bundesliga gefällt mir auch noch gut, also ich gehe auch noch zur Bundesliga, weil die Stimmung finde ich da auch immer noch ganz gut. Aber ist nicht zu vergleichen mit dem argentinischen Stadion, wenn du dann eine Fanszene hast oder das Stadion, das halt einfach mal 90 Minuten lang die eigene Mannschaft unterstützt und mit so vielen verschiedenen Liedern. Also da ist ja auch so eine Sache im Vergleich zu Deutschland, wo viele Lieder kopiert werden aus dem Ausland, wo wenig selbst tatsächlich kreiert wird. Und da gibt es jetzt in Argentinien, wenn ich mich vielleicht mit dem ein oder anderen argentinischen Fußballfan vielleicht jetzt anfeinde. Aber ich finde zum Beispiel die Fanszene von San Lorenzo da hingehend vielleicht die beste, weil die sehr nahe. Also die Kapelle, die haben halt auch immer Instrumente dabei. Mehrere Leute, da spielen dann zehn Leute Instrumente von irgendwie Trompete über Trommeln. Und da ist halt richtig was los. Und San Lorenzo hat halt diese Nähe zum Karneval, der ja in Südamerika. Oder sagen wir mal, in Argentinien jetzt nicht ganz so groß ist wie in Brasilien beispielsweise, aber trotzdem noch eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Und diese Fanszene hat halt irgendwie die besten, ja, vielleicht nicht die besten Lieder, aber es sind somit die ersten, die mit neuen Liedern und neuen Themen rauskommen. Und wenn du dann halt ins Stadion gehst, du hörst halt eine Vielzahl verschiedener Lieder und verschiedener Melodien mit verschiedenen Texten. Und ich hab halt oft das Gefühl, dass die Fans vor Ort sich tatsächlich, also 24-7 mit dem Thema Fußball und wie kann ich meine Mannschaft unterstützen, dass sie sich damit beschäftigen und viel Zeit investieren und dementsprechend am Sonntag, dem traditionellen Tag im argentinischen Fußball, halt top performen, also die Fans.
Und wie ist der Fußball?
Der Fußball ist meiner Meinung nach besser geworden in den letzten zwei Jahren. Er ist, um das jetzt mal auf die Bundesliga umzumünzen, ja, irgendwo zwischen erster und zweiter Liga anzusiedeln. Boca und River werden sicherlich nicht gegen den Abstieg spielen in der Bundesliga, dazu sind die Mannschaften zu gut. Sie würden aber auch nicht um die Meisterschaft mitspielen, aber sie könnten so, ja, das ist so eine, je nach Tagesform, halt vielleicht erste Hälfte der Liga. Und wenn sie Glück, gutes Jahr haben, dann würden sie sich für ein internationales Geschäft qualifizieren. Aber du hast natürlich auch viele Mannschaften, die sich hinten reinstellen und kloppen, weil der argentinische Fußball sehr viele Zweikämpfer hat. Also weniger Kombinationsfußball wie jetzt der europäische Fußball, sondern da geht es viel mehr Mann gegen Mann. Und da musst du, sagen wir mal so, da kannst du als Einzelspieler dich vielleicht nicht hinter einem System verstecken, sondern du musst tatsächlich dein Mann stehen auf dem Platz. Und das ist halt auch das, was die Leute sehen wollen. Und wenn du, da musst du als Spieler auch liefern.
Ja, ganz interessant, das habe ich mir auch mal angesehen. So die Statistiken der Argentinischen Liga, die jetzt gerade so irgendwo zwischen dem 11. und 12. Spieltag steht, haben nicht alle Mannschaften gleich viele Spiele. Aber da gibt es allein acht Mannschaften, die mehr als 20 Taglings pro Spiel ausführen. Da dachte ich mir auch, also das kommt mir sehr hoch vor. Das vergleiche ich jetzt mal mit der Bundesliga. Und siehe da, keine einzige Mannschaft in der Liga hat überhaupt 20 Taglings. Am nächsten kommt noch Leverkusen mit 19,7 Taglings. Also das, was du beschreibst mit den vielen Zweikämpfen, die geführt werden, eben dann auch in Form von Taglings, das drückt sich da eindeutig in den Zahlen aus. Und auch das, was du mit dem hinten reinstellen besprochen hast. Die Passquoten sind nicht die besten. Das ist etwas, wo natürlich ich als Konne-Sir des guten Fußballs als erstes draufguck. Die gehen ein bisschen, aber das zeigt ja schon, es ist ein sehr körperbetonter Fußball. Das finde ich ja interessant. Wir haben ja durchaus andere Fußballkulturen, wo es dann ein bisschen anders gelagert ist. Jetzt sagen wir aber mal, dieser Super-Klassik, dieses Spiel zwischen Boca Juniors und River Plate. Was macht denn das so besonders? Woher kommt jetzt diese globale Aufmerksamkeit? Sogar der Rasenfunk macht jetzt mal was zum argentinischen Fußball.
Also ich denke mir einfach mal, also erstens, das sind die zwei größte Mannschaften in Argentinien. Und nicht nur in Argentinien, sondern das sind auch mit die größte Mannschaften in ganz Südamerika. Wenn wir jetzt nur über die Copa Libertadores sprechen oder über internationale Pokalspiele, dann sind es die zwei Schwergewichte auch. Also es gibt ja auch Rankings im Cormnibol. Also das Südamerikanische Fußballverband. Genau, das Südamerikanische Fußballverband. Und die führen die beiden Mannschaften an. Also River und Boca sind, da gibt es so Berechnungs-, also da geht es über so einen Koeffizienten, wie du in den letzten zehn Jahren performt hast. Und wie viele internationale Titel du natürlich geholt hast in deiner Historie. Und da ist es so, dass River und Boca oben sind. Dann hast du so Mannschaften wie Gremio oder Nacional aus Uruguay, Olympia aus Paraguay. Aber es gibt so zwei verschiedene Berechnungsschlüssel. Und in beiden hast du River und Boca halt ganz oben. Und Boca hat sechsmal den Titel geholt, River dreimal. Und darüber gibt es nur Independiente, die auch aus Argentinien stammen. Die haben sieben Titel. Da hat Boca die Chance aufzuschließen. Deswegen glaubt man wahrscheinlich in Independiente oder hofft man, dass River das Ding holt. Und man noch eine Weile diesen Sonnenplatz hat. Aber Argentinien ist Fußball. Mit Abstand sind das die größten Clubs in Argentinien. Die kommen beide aus einer Stadt. Die beiden Städte entstehen 14 Kilometer auseinander. In Deutschland oder in Europa wird man schnell von einem Klassiker, das ist eigentlich nur derby-Bedeutet, gesprochen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, für mich muss ein Derby in der gleichen Stadt stattfinden. Es kann nicht sein, dass Barcelona, Madrid oder Dortmund, Bayern keine Klassikos sind. In dem Sinne, die werden ja Klassiker. Irgendwie das. So kann man das ausdrücken. Aber Klassiker im ursprünglichen Sinne von Derby, das ist ein Stadt-Duell.
Brauchst du auch eine Stadt, wo die beiden Städte in 14 Kilometer auseinanderstehen können und trotzdem noch zur gleichen Stadt gehören.
Hast du in Buenos Aires, wenn jeder dritte Staatsbürger aus Buenos Aires kommt, du hast ja nicht nur Boca und River. Ich hatte ja San Lorenzo angesprochen, ist ja auch Buenos Aires. Du hast Interveniente Racing, die vor den Toren von Buenos Aires, immer noch Gran-Buenos Aires. Also gehörst du zu Buenos Aires, aber nicht zum Stadtkern. Und du hast halt einfach die halbe Liga besteht aus Mannschaften aus Buenos Aires. Und dann hast du Rosario, wo Messi herkommt, das Newells und Central, die beiden Mannschaften. Dann hast du Córdoba, hast noch Mannschaften. Du hast schon noch ein paar verteilt, aber so die großen, die Big Guns, die kommen alle aus Buenos Aires. Und bei Boca sagt man ja la mitad más uno, also die Hälfte plus eins soll bedeuten, im Land gibt es 50 plus eins Fans, die sind Boca.
Ah, das argentinische 50 plus eins, das kannte ich noch gar nicht.
Ja, la mitad más uno, 50 plus eins. Aber gut, klar, das hat da eine andere Bedeutung im Sinne von, die Hälfte plus eins ist Fan von Boca und River hingegen ist der argentinische Rekordmeister. Hat zwar im Vergleich mit Boca den Kürzeren gezogen, also Boca gewinnt mehr Spiele als der River. 89 zu 82 steht es da, 247 Spiele zugunsten von Boca. Und es ist halt schwer, das sind halt echt beide richtig krasse Schwergewichte. Ich will dir jetzt mal ganz kurz mal für dich eine Challenge. Ich habe mir jetzt eine Liste geschrieben, die lese ich dir jetzt mal ganz kurz vor und du sagst mir, was das sein könnte. Was haben diese Menschen gemacht? Diego Maradona, Claudio Canicia, Mario Kempes, Marcelo Salas, Roman Riquelme, Javier Saviola, Pablo Aymar, Martin Palermo, Esteban Cambiasso, Marcelo Gallardo, Guillermo Barrosquelotto, Andres de Alessandro, Radam el Falcao, Manuel Lanzini und Televacuzna Lucas Alario.
Okay, also es sind auf jeden Fall Spieler von beiden Teams, nicht nur von Boca. Dann sind es welche, die Torschützen in den Derbys waren.
Das sind alles Torschützen und man spricht.
Aber damit hat man ja auch schon ganz gut so ein bisschen abgedeckt, wer da schon alles gespielt hat. Also sehr, sehr, sehr gute Liste. Kannte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht alle. Da muss ich ein paar nochmal nachgugeln, aber halt auch sehr klangvolle Namen mit dabei. Das zeigt ja schon.
Ich glaube, du kanntest alle. Vielleicht habe ich sie ein bisschen sehr Argentino ausgesprochen. Du kennst sie alle.
Ja, ist schön, dass du mir das einfach unterstellst. Nehmen wir das einfach mal an, fühle ich mich natürlich auch viel, viel besser mit.
Da waren auch beide Trainer dabei. Vielleicht kennt man so Gichelmo, Baros Gelotto jetzt erstmal nicht, aber das ist der Trainer von Boca und ist einer der Rekordspieler bei Boca. Und die anderen, Lanzini beispielsweise, der bei West Ham spielt, der die WM wegen Kreuzbandriss verpasst hat, der hat das schnellste Tor der Geschichte geschossen in einem Superclassico. Und von denen, den ich vorgelesen habe, Martin Palermo, der Rekordtorschütze von Boca Juniors. Allein über den könnte man ja mehrere Bücher füllen, eine unglaubliche Karriere. Unglaublich, der Toroptimist. Da haben wir auch einen schönen Artikel in AjiFootball. Absolut lesenswert. Unglaublicher Typ. Der hat allein neunmal getroffen in Superclassicos. Das ist teilweise die creme de la creme des argentinischen Fußballs. Auch der letzte Jahre. Ich hätte die Liste noch weitermachen können. Aber das ist einfach das Spiel in Argentinien. Da ist natürlich in Brasilien vielleicht hier und da noch ein paar ganz gute Duelle. Wenn Flamengo dabei ist. Das ist ja so der größte Club in ganz Südamerika. Flamengo. Aber ein besseres Derby meiner Meinung nach gibt es nicht. Und Copa Libertadores hatte noch nie ein argentinisches Finale. Das erste Mal.
Und dann jetzt auch noch dieses.
Dann jetzt auch noch dieses und zeitgleich. Es ist das letzte Mal, dass Hin- und Rückspiele in einem Finale bestritten werden. Das ist natürlich auch nochmal besonders.
Absolut. Man sagt ja immer, von Europa aus gesehen, die Copa Libertadores wäre so ein bisschen die Champions League Südamerikas. Stimmt das auch, wenn man jetzt mal so die Bedeutung dieses Titels einordnet, die er für die argentinischen Fußballfans und die anderen südamerikanischen Fußballfans hat?
Absolut. Also es ist genauso, wie du sagst, es ist der Wettbewerb. Es ist den Pokal, den du holen willst, den du holen musst, wenn du Boca oder River heißt, dann ist das das Ziel. Natürlich, wenn du jetzt auf die Tabelle guckst und dir erst mal denkst, oh River und Boca spielen da jetzt in der argentinischen Liga. Gerade aktuell, ja keine sehr wichtige Rolle, sind für den Verfolgerfeld dabei, aber das kannst du dir genau damit erklären. Also die wollen die Libertadores gewinnen, wenn sie den Meister schafft. Boca ist in den letzten beiden Jahren Meister geworden. River ist immer noch der Rekordmeister. Da kannst du zwar sagen, okay, da muss man langsam wieder einen Meistertitel her, aber die wollen die Libertadores gewinnen, das ist ganz klar. Dem wird alles untergeordnet.
Und die Saison ist ja noch jung, also der Rhythmus ist ja anders als hier in Europa. Jetzt findet das Finale in der Copa statt und die Saison hatte erst eben zehn bis zwölf Spieltage, je nachdem, bei welchem Team man gespielt hat.
Genau, River hat ein bisschen weniger aufgrund der Copaspiele. Die haben ja beispielsweise zwei Spiele weniger. Aber ja, das ist das. Und Rassing, der Tabellenführer, der hat halt, River hat im Achtelfinale gegen Rassing gespielt und Rassing auch bezogen. Ansonsten, man stelle sich vor, es wäre andersrum gewesen, dann würde Rassing, ich wage mal jetzt das zu behaupten, auch nicht auf Platz eins stehen. Weil diese Kader in Südamerika, die sind oftmals, Boca und River mögen eine Ausnahme sein, dann vor allem Boca, die eine unglaubliche Bank haben, aber ansonsten so drei Wettbewerbe packen die normal nicht. Du hast ja noch die Argentinischen Pokal, die Copa Argentina und im Normalfall ist das zu viel für einen Kader. Du musst auch sehen, dass diese Distanzen, die da teilweise zurückgelegt werden in der Libertadores, wenn du irgendwo auswärts spielst, in Bolivien auf, was weiß ich, 3000 Meter Höhe oder so, auf dem Acker letztlich, der Rasen ist schlecht, die Bedingungen sind nicht so gut, die Reisestrapazen, was kommt noch dazu, wenn du irgendwo auswärts spielst? Du spielst vielleicht bei einem kleineren Team und die ziehen halt alle Register, dass du in deinem Hotel, es gibt kein warmes Wasser, du hast Fans, die dich nicht schlafen lassen. Also diese kleine, diese Folklore, diese kleinen Tricks, die du noch machen kannst, es passiert da tatsächlich noch was, ja hier in Europa, ja, sag mal, kaum noch passiert, aber da wird echt noch mit allen Bandagen gekämpft und es ist halt einfach anstrengender. Und wenn du da vorhin hast, du hast ja selbst die Statistik genannt, diese Spiele, die gehen halt echt an die Substanz. Und dann ist es halt schwer, in allen Wettbewerben richtig abzuliefern.
Und jetzt gibt es zum allerersten Mal eben den Superklassico im wichtigsten Spiel, im wichtigsten Wettbewerb, deswegen all dieser Hype. Jetzt sagen wir mal, wie lief denn das Hinspiel? Ich habe die Highlights gesehen. Es ging 2 zu 2 aus in La Bombonera, also bei Boca Juniors. Das Ganze ohne Gäste-Fans, weil da schon so viel passiert ist bei vergangenen Derbys. Unglaublich merkwürdige Atmosphäre bei den Treffern für River Plate, muss man sagen. Ganz interessant, dass man da wirklich gar nichts hört, nicht mal ein Ausschrei bei den Boca Juniors-Fans. Also ganz interessante, intensive Atmosphäre, wie lief es denn sportlich gesehen?
Ich fand's ein gutes Spiel, aber gerade die erste Halbzeit fand ich sehr gut, sehr abwechslungsreich. Ich bin etwas enttäuscht von Boca, weil ich mir einfach gedacht habe, du musst als Heimmannschaft einfach ein bisschen dominanter auftreten. Und wenn man mal ehrlich ist und sich die beiden Tore von Boca anguckt, die sind ja auch eher aus dem Nichts gefallen. Und River hat gerade in der ersten Halbzeit, also Boca fand ich total den Schneid abgekauft. Das hatten sie schon in der Liga. Da hat River auch in der Bombonera gewonnen. Und es war einfach nur eine Fortführung dessen. Ich war überrascht, weil Boca eigentlich mit dem besten Kader, also gut nimm mal den linksverteidiger Fabre, der schon länger wegen Kreuzbandriss ausfällt, mit der besten Mannschaft ins Spiel gegangen. Und River hingegen war ohne Trainer da und ohne ihren Kapitän.
Weil er im Halbfinale der Trainer Gallardo hatte, ein Verbot mit seinen Spielern zu kommunizieren und hat sich daran nicht gehalten.
Genauso war es. Genauso war es. In der Halbzeit ist er dann in die Katakomben und hat dann den Kontakt gesucht und hat mit seinen Spielern geredet, das durfte er nicht. Er wurde aufgrund dieser Aktion gesperrt und durfte auch nicht ins Stadion. Im Vergleich zum Rückspiel-Halbfinale durfte er nicht auf die Trainerbank. Da war er schon verboten, mit seiner Mannschaft zu kommunizieren, schon im zweiten Halbfinale. Und dann zusätzlich durch diese Aktion haben sie gesagt, dieses Mal darfst du gar nicht ins Stadion, du musst zu Hause bleiben.
Und wie kam es zu dem Verbot? Warum hat man ihn von seiner Mannschaft weggehalten im Halbfinale? Hat er sich zu sehr aufgeregt gegenüber dem Schiedsrichter? Oder was ist da passiert?
Nein, eigentlich eine La Palia, der seiner Mannschaft zu spät auf den Platz gekommen ist.
Ach, und dafür wird dann gleich der Trainer bestraft?
Genau. Ja, weil man sagt, der Trainer ist dafür verantwortlich. Es war nach der Halbzeitpause, dass die Mannschaft rechtzeitig wieder da ist. Die sind kam zu spät und dann wurde, ja, kann man natürlich auch sagen, jetzt ein bisschen hart. Also ist jetzt nichts vorgefallen. Ist sowieso eine Sache, ich bin ein großer Fan auch von Marcelo Gachardo, würde ich mal übrigens sagen. Ein Doppel L in Argentinien ist immer so wie ein SCH auszusprechen. Gachardo. Ich bin ein großer Fan von El Muñeco, von der Puppe, wie er genannt wird, weil er ein absoluter Gentleman ist, sehr eloquent, sehr klug, auch derzeit wahrscheinlich der beste Trainer in Argentinien, also in der Argentinischen Liga. Vielleicht zusammen mit Ariel Olland, der bei Independiente trainiert. Von daher ist es sehr schade, dass du so eine Persönlichkeit aus so einem Finalspiel, so ein besonderes Spiel ausschließt. Auf der anderen Seite kannst du natürlich verstehen, dass er im Halbfinale noch mal die Ansage machen musste, aus seiner Sicht, weil River doch ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen glücklich, weil sie eigentlich ganz gut gespielt haben, aber letztendlich, wie die Tore gefallen sind, doch ein bisschen glücklich weitergekommen sind, auch gegen eine Mannschaft, die gegen den Titelverteidiger, die auch eine super Truppe haben. Und auswärts musst du das Ding auch erst noch mal drehen können. Ja, für uns natürlich super, für uns, sag ich mal, die argentinischen Fußball lieben super. Natürlich schade, dass da im Hinspiel Gaschardor nicht dabei sein konnte.
Der Herr ist noch sehr jung, also mit 42 Jahren, weil du gesagt hast, Gentleman, da stellt man sich vielleicht als Hörerin oder Hörer einen 60-jährigen Othmar Hitzfeld oder einen 70-jährigen Jupp Heynckes vor. Aber der SS 42 hat noch gespielt bis 2011 und ist aber schon seit unglaublichen 202 Spielen Trainer bei River Plate.
Genau. Ich bin mir sicher, einige Hörer kennen ihn wohl noch. Er hat ja 46 Länder Spiele gemacht für Argentinien und hat bei Monaco, bei Peugeot gespielt, als Spieler, die Copa Libertadores gewonnen. Sechsmal Meister mit River als Spieler, Meister mit Monaco, Pokalsieger mit Monaco und mit Peugeot. Dann war er noch mal in Uruguay zu seinem Karriereende, ist da auch noch mal Meister geworden mit Nacional, also aus Montevideo. Das war auch seine erste Trainerstation und ist da auch sofort Meister geworden. Er kam dann direkt zu River Plate und hat da auch sämtliche Titel abgeräumt. Copa Sudamericana, was man mit der Europa League vergleichen kann und im Folgejahr die Libertadores in 2015. Auch wenn man sich mal Interviews mit ihm anhört, wie er spricht und wie reflektiert er ist in einem überhitzten argentinischen oder südamerikanischen Fußball, ist er da eher eine Ausnahme. Und das gefällt mir halt. Und man muss halt auch echt sagen, River spielt auch echt einen guten Ball. Also das ist, ich sage immer, wenn mich jemand fragt zu River und Boca, Boca hat den besseren Kader. Ich glaube, da gibt es keine zwei Meinungen. Also gerade in der Tiefe, die Bank ist unglaublich. Also das ist einzigartig in ganz Südamerika, die Bank, die Boca hat. Aber ich finde trotzdem, das merkst du immer im Superklassico, River spielt einfach besser. Die haben den reiferen Ansatz. Und das ist, Gashado ist einfach flexibler. Der stellt seine Mannschaft einfach besser ein, währenddessen es Gelotte auf der Gegenseite halt oft sein 4-3-3 durchzieht. Der hat auch die Spieler für das System, aber es ist halt irgendwie, bei River das float einfach mehr. Die Mannschaft ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen besser zusammengestellt für das System, das Gashado ihnen abverlangt. Und deswegen hat es mich jetzt nicht überrascht, dass River sich gut geschlagen hat. Allerdings hätte ich mir schon von Boca irgendwie erhofft, im Heimspiel auch nach der Niederlage vor sieben, acht Wochen. Dass die da einfach ein bisschen dominanter zu Werke gehen. Weil letztendlich ist ihr Go-to-Guy Christian Pavon nach 25 Minuten verletzt runter. Und selbst mit Pavon hat es nicht so gut ausgesehen nach vorne, weil die eigentlich auch fast jeden Ball auf ihn gespielt haben. Und wenn was gegangen ist, dann über ihn. Und dann war er runter und dann, die hatten halt keine Ideen. Also wenig Ideen und kamen dann halt eher glücklich zur Führung. Ja, Torwartfehler will ich jetzt nicht nennen, aber Armani, der Tormann von River, gilt als derzeit der beste Torwart in Südamerika.
Also er sah ein bisschen unglücklich aus bei Nutz. Dafür hat er dann das 2 zu 2 festgehalten in der 90. Minute. Da hätte Boca noch mit einer Riesenchance das 3-2 machen können. Gibt es denn die Auswärtstor-Regel in der Copa?
Im Finale nicht.
Ach okay, interessant.
Gibt es im Finale nicht, was jetzt natürlich diesen Erfolg von River ein bisschen schmälert. Also sie müssen gewinnen, beziehungsweise wenn es unentschieden ausgeht, dann geht es in die Verlängerung und dann geht es ins Elfmeterschießen. Von daher ist es natürlich ein bisschen blöd für River, weil sie auch ihren Stürmer, ihren Colombianer vorne drin, haben sie jetzt auch verloren. Ich eine gelbe Karte, das war ja unnötig. Auf der Gegenseite Boca hat Pavón verloren durch die Verletzung. Es wird auch nicht fit. Auf der anderen Seite, wie ich schon angedeutet habe, das Boca steckt sowas weg. Dann spielt halt Carlos Tevez. Der nur auf der Bank saß im Hinspielen und jetzt spielt Tevez. Und River kann jetzt Santos Bode, der junge Colombianer, so ein sehr Emsiger, ein guter Fußballer und einer, der viel unterwegs ist und schwer zu verteidigen. Sein Backup ist auch verletzt. Den können sie nicht so einfach ersetzen. Ich bin gespannt, wer auch das Zepter übernimmt. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass die in der ersten Halbzeit erstmal abwartend agieren, aber es ist alles offen. Die letzten Spiele zwischen den beiden, wenn einer gewonnen hat, dann die Auswärtsmannschaft gewonnen. Von daher sind wir mal gespannt, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass wir in Verlängerung gehen. Es werden Details sein, es wird ein unglaublich tolles Spiel. Da bin ich mir sicher, die Stimmung wird natürlich gigantisch sein, auch wenn mir das Monumental im Vergleich zu Bombonera nicht so gefällt, weil da eine Tatal-Bahn drumrum ist, da bist du nicht so nah dran. Gut, ich bin ja eh nicht im Stadion. Aber ich bin mir sicher, die brennen da ein Feuerwerk ab. Das wird ein sehr hitziges Spiel. Da ist ja auch einige richtige Kerle auf dem Platz. Die haben sich im Hinspiel zurückgehalten, weil einige gelb vorbelastet waren. Und keiner wollte das Finale-Rückspiel verlieren und nicht mitmachen können. Und jetzt bin ich mir sicher, das geht richtig zur Sache im Rückspielen. Da wird einiges an außergewöhnlichen Grätschen oder ein paar schlimmeren Aktionen. Das wird man auf jeden Fall sehen.
Und wir werden auf jeden Fall auch einen alten Bekannten aus der Bundesliga sehen. Bei River spielt Javier Pinola in der Innenverteidigung. Inzwischen 35 Jahre alt. Wir alle kennen ihn noch, auch mit recht eigenwilligen Frisuren. Manchmal beim 1. FC Nürnberg war er unterwegs. Und wenn ich mir angucke, wie hat die Abwehr von River so performt in der Liga, dann sehe ich, oh, erst fünf Gegentreffer, damit beste Abwehr. Erst ein Gegentreffer aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus. Also verteidigen kann River eigentlich?
Ja, River kann eigentlich alles. Vor allem bei Pinola spielt er Innenverteidigung. Und zusammen mit Maidana, der ein ähnliches Alter hat, sind das zwei richtig gestandene Innenverteidiger. Das ist auch die einzige Position, wo ich sage, da ist River im Vergleich zu Boca besser aufgestellt. Ich bin kein Fan von Maidana beispielsweise. Ist auch wie Pinola. Beide sind zu langsam und haben eigentlich auch Maidana-Schwächen im Spielaufbau beispielsweise. Aber das sind halt richtige Monster, die beiden. Im Zweikampf, von ihrer Mentalität her, richtige Gewinnertypen. Die Stürmer haben schon ein bisschen Angst vor den beiden. Maidana ist ein richtig harter Hund und Pinola kann das auch. Die Stürmer haben einfach einen ganz schweren Stand. Aber die ganze Mannschaft verteidigt einfach gut. Mit Poncio, der Kapitän, der spielt auf der 6. Das ist ja auch einer. Der ist ja fast noch schlimmer als die beiden.
Auch schon 36.
Auch schon 36, aber auch in der EU, also Europarefahrung, abgewichster Typ und halt überhart. Also richtig hart. Auf der Gegenseite bei Boca hast du auch so einen Wilmar Barrios, der Colombian.
Den kennen wir auch von der WM, oder?
Den kennen wir von der WM, der hat eine gute WM gespielt, der eigentlich relativ dünn ist und drahtig, aber auch ein richtiger Kämpfer, ein richtig harter Typ. Auch ein toller Fußballer, also jetzt kein Tripler oder so, aber der kann auch elegant in die Zweikämpfe und die Bälle erobern, aber der lässt auch gerne krachen im Zweikampf. Dann hast du jemanden wie Nahid Dandandes, wo Stuttgart-Interesse nachgesagt wird beispielsweise, der ist auch ein richtiger Hund auf dem Platz, sehr viel unterwegs, hart. Pablo Pérez bei Boca, ähnlicher Fall, auch sehr aggressiv. Also das zentrale Mittelfeld von Boca. Da hast du drei gestandene Männer. Und auf der Gegenseite bei River...
Spielen die dann da ein Sechser und zwei Achter? Also sind jetzt Nandés und Pérez dann die beiden Achter und Barrios der Sechser, wenn du sagst, im 4-3-3?
Meistens. Meistens spielen sie so. Aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, wie sie im Rückspiel spielen, weil wie gesagt, Pavón ist so der Schlüsselspieler bei Boca. Und der spielt, der ist ein Außenstürmer, und der spielt meistens links außen, er ist ein Rechtsfuß, aber spielt meistens links außen. Und wie gesagt, der spielt nicht. Und von daher könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sie vielleicht mit einer Doppelspitze anfangen. Sie haben ja mit Benedetto den Torjäger überhaupt, der natürlich jetzt auch lange verletzt war, weil so langsam wieder dran ist, der sie auch ins Finale geschossen hat. Und mit Avila ihr auch so ein Stoßstürmer. Und es kann auch gut sein, dass beide spielen und dass sie dann irgendwie ein bisschen umstellen. Nandez kann auch auf die Außen gehen. Nandez kannst du überall eigentlich hinstellen. Also der liefert. Und ja, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, wie sie tatsächlich sich aufstellen werden. Und Carlos Tevez, denke ich, werden wir auch sehen im Finale. Also mal schauen, wie sich das dann letztendlich auftut. Es kann sein, dass Pérez ein bisschen weiter nach links geht und Nandez ein bisschen weiter nach rechts. Barrios wird auf der 6 bleiben, Tevez auf die 10 und zwei Mittelstürmer. Kann so sein, muss nicht so sein. Boca's Kader gibt echt viel her. Haben wir übrigens noch einen mit dem kleinen Bruder von Sergio Sarate. Sagt dir der Name noch was?
Na klar, Sarate, ja.
Genau. Und sein kleiner Bruder, das sind ja vier Brüder, die alle Fußballer waren, und der jüngste von denen ist der Mauro. Und der steht ja auch bei Boca und der Vertrag. Und der ist ja, das ist auch so ein richtiger Allrounder. Also ich hab ihn dieses Jahr im Stadion gesehen, da hat er bei Veles, Veles Sarsfield noch gespielt. Und da hab ich ihn allein in dem Spiel auf vier Positionen gesehen. Also von Mittelstürmer, Zehner, Sechser und zeitweise sogar als Innenverteidiger.
Und das ist der Bruder von Sardjow Sarate, der mal irgendwann bei Nürnberg gespielt hat. Der hatte doch so geilen Locken. Aber es ist doch schon ewig her, dass der...
Die sind fast 20 Jahre auseinander oder so. Aber Mauro ist so der beste Fußballer von den vier Brüdern. Aber das waren vier, das sind alles Fußballprofis geworden. Und der Roli, Rolando Sarate, das ist der zweitjüngste, der ist auch der Berater von Mauro. Der ist so ein Familiending. Die haben alle mal bei Vélez Sars viel gespielt. Und jetzt bei Boca, da gab es einen Riesenskandal, dass er diesen Wechsel gemacht hat, auch gegen den Rat seines Bruders. Aber Mauro, um wieder auf die Libertadores zurückzukommen, der will den Titel. Und mit Vélez gewinnst du den nicht. Und ja, der will die Libertadores gewinnen. Und deswegen ist er zu Boca gegangen.
Jetzt haben wir viele erfahrene Spieler. Ein paar junge haben wir jetzt auch schon genannt. Also Pavón zum Beispiel ist 22, der jetzt ja leider verletzt ist. Und du hast ja auch schon bei manchen jetzt gesagt, da gibt es auch Interesse europäischer Vereine. Glaubst du, es gibt Spieler, die jetzt in diesem Finale auf dem Spielfeld stehen werden, die wir in Zukunft vielleicht auch noch mal im europäischen Fußball sehen? Oder ist dafür das Zeitfenster dann bei den meisten doch schon geschlossen? Weil wir so die richtigen jungen Talente, die 18-Jährigen, die 19-Jährigen, sehe ich jetzt kaum in den beiden Kadern.
Also du hast da mit Ezequiel Palacios bei River auf der Acht. Den werden wir auf alle Fälle in Europa sehen. Wir werden auch Christian Pavón auf alle Fälle in Europa sehen. Und Wilmar Barrios werden wir auch sehen. Wir werden Naitan Andes sehen. Also da bin ich mir total sicher, dass das passiert. Fabra hast du jetzt nicht gesehen. Das ist der Linksverteidiger, auch ein Kolumbianer. Der war eigentlich mit Everton schon klar. Aber hat sich dann wie gesagt das Kreuzband gerissen. Ist auch ein kolumbianischer Nationalspieler. Wen haben wir denn da noch? Santos Bode könnte ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass der noch mal in die europäische Top-Liga wechselt. Portugal vielleicht mal als ersten Schritt oder so was. Aber da sind schon einige. Palacios auf jeden Fall, da ist Serie A, Madrid sogar an ihm dran. Ich dachte, der erste wäre nur ein Gerücht. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass sich da Pérez für ihn interessiert und sogar direkt den Kontakt zum Spieler gesucht hat, was jetzt bei der Klubführung bei River nicht gut angekommen ist.
Ja, gut, wo kommt sowas schon gut an? Also ist das auch immer noch das Ziel von argentinischen Spielern? Ist das Ziel dann schon eher noch Europa, wenn man in einem Alter ist, indem man da noch gefragt ist? Ein paar von denen, die du genannt hast, waren auch schon Mitte 20. Aber das kann einem ja egal sein, wenn ein Klub anklopft. Glaubst du, das ist schon immer noch für die ein Ziel, den Kontinentnummer zu wechseln?
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Da gibt es auch diese Hintergedanken der Nationalmannschaft. Wenn du in der Argentinischen Liga spielst und du spielst gegen den Defenser Hustizia, Ignacia, du musst dich mit dem Besten der Welt messen. Du weißt, wie es ist. Wenn du in der Nationalmannschaft eine Rolle spielen willst, dann musst du nach Europa. Das ist klar für jemanden, der bei Boca oder bei River spielt, die haben gute Verträge, die haben Megastar-Potenzial in der Stadt, die werden überall erkannt. Das ist, wenn die nach Europa kommen, dann nicht mehr der Fall, außer bei den absoluten Topstars. Also auch so ein Pavón beispielsweise. Pavón ist jetzt auch nicht –ich glaube, dem geht es ganz gut, Boca. Der muss jetzt auch nicht wechseln. Der muss ja 50 Millionen für ihn auf den Tisch legen, wenn du ihn haben willst. der Spieler kann diese Klausel ziehen. Boca könnte ihn auch für weniger verkaufen, wenn sie das wollten. Aber der fühlt sich da auch erstmal wohl, ist auch noch jung. Trotzdem, das Ziel eines jeden Spieler, egal wo der spielt, in Argentinien, ist Europa. Und da ist es auch erstmal egal, welche Liga. Die Premier League ist sehr präsent. Wegen der Sprache ist natürlich Spanien interessant, oder Italien, weil viele italienische Wurzeln haben. Aber selbst die Bundesliga ist für die Jungs interessant. Aber es ist auch so, dass die meisten Bundesligamannschaften nicht so den argentinischen Markt weniger im Fokus haben, wenn du jetzt mal Leverkusen und Stuttgart wegnimmst, hier und da, vielleicht Frankfurt auch noch. Es gibt so ein paar, die sind ganz gut informiert, die vielleicht auch ein persönliches Interesse haben. So ein Jonas Boldt war ja auch mal in Buenos Aires, und ein Reschke weiß man ja auch, dass er sehr argentinienaffin ist. Aber es gibt viele andere, die lieber Europäer unter Vertrag nehmen oder wenn Südamerikaner dann vielleicht nach Brasilien gucken oder so. Oder in kleinere Länder. Kolumbien bringt ja auch hervorragende Spieler raus, die dann auch billiger sind. Und von daher ist dieses Match Deutschland-Agentinen, wenn, dann eher was ein Länderspiel, aber weniger, dass jetzt die Clubs großartig in Argentinien einkaufen würden.
Ja, aber lass da nochmal kurz die letzten Minuten drauf verwenden, auf die Situation des argentinischen Fußballs auch von der Nationalmannschaft her betrachtet. Also wenn ich mir jetzt die Copa Libertadores als Wettbewerb angucke, dann haben wir da eine argentinische Dominanz. Von 58 Titeln gegen 24 nach Argentinien und 34 Mal, also in über der Hälfte aller Finalspiele, standen argentinische Vereine im Finale, gefolgt dann von Brasilien, aber mit einem für mich dann relativ deutlichen Abstand. Also sechs Titel weniger, Finale teilnahmen ungefähr gleich. Das heißt, wenig überraschend, Argentinien und Brasilien spielen die größte Rolle in dieser südamerikanischen Champions League. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber die Nationalmannschaften angucke, dann habe ich da ein anderes Bild. Wir erinnern uns in der WM ausgeschieden gegen Frankreich mit diesem 3 zu 4 im Achtelfinale, auch nur relativ wackelig gegen Nigeria weitergekommen. Und Sampaoli, der Trainer, ward dann nicht mehr Trainer. Was hat sich denn getan im argentinischen Fußball? Und wie würdest du die Rolle der argentinischen Nationalmannschaft einschätzen?
Also erstmal die Albi Celeste, wie sie genannt werden, die Himmelblauen, wurde jetzt komplett neu aufgebaut. Also da ist ja fast gar keiner mehr dabei aus dem letzten Turnier. Selbst Messi ist nicht dabei und es ist auch noch nicht klar, ob er überhaupt zurückkommt. Er ist ja erstmal zurückgetreten, vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber hat sich eine Pause genommen. Und dieser Schnitt wurde gemacht jetzt. Und er hätte halt schon viel früher kommen müssen. Aber das Problem war halt, Messi ist halt eine unglaubliche dominante Person innerhalb dieser Albi Celeste und hat irgendwie die Eigenart oder das Verlangen, diese Turniere mit seinen Buddys zu spielen, die vielleicht da auch einfach nicht mehr hingehören. Und du hast es ja auch gesehen, die argentinische Mannschaft, also das ist ja schon seit Jahren, dass die nicht gut spielt. Die sind zwar in viele Finale eingezogen, auch Copa America gegen Deutschland im Finale gestanden. Das waren ja dann innerhalb von zwei Jahren, weil die Copa America zweimal ausgetragen wurde, waren das ja dann drei Finale, die alle verloren wurden. Mit Nulltoren, also du hast nie geschafft, zu treffen. Wurde zweimal ein Elfmeterschießen gegen Chile bezwungen und gegen Deutschland hier mit dem Tor in der Nachspielzeit. Also sie können es eigentlich. Aber was die argentinischen Mannschaften eigentlich immer ausgemacht hat, dieser Spielwitz, dieser Offensivgeist –und dafür haben sie ja die Spieler im Kader eigentlich. Es ist ja eigentlich vom Kader her keine Mannschaft, auch noch nie gewesen, die sich über eine Defensive wirklich definiert. Aber das siehst du gar nicht. Das siehst du seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr. Die haben so große Probleme, sich überhaupt Chancen rauszuspielen. Die sind dominant, die haben den Ball und der Ball läuft irgendwie, aber sehr anfällig auf Konter. Die Mannschaft scheint überhaupt nicht eingespielt. Der Teamgeist ist auch fast nicht vorhanden. Du hast keinen Leader, weil Messi auch einfach kein Leader ist, in dem Sinne. Und ja, dieses ganze Konstrukt, die AFA ist auch nicht besonders gut organisiert. Dann kommen dann viele von den Megastars aus Europa zurück und die lachen sich halt auch so ein bisschen kaputt über die Sachen organisiert in Argentinien. Da fängt das schon an, wie die Auswärtsfahrten organisiert sind, die Flüge, die gechattert werden, die Busse, die Hotels und diese ganze Spielvorbereitung. Und das spielt alles so ein bisschen eine Rolle. Und ich glaube einfach, dass diese Stars sich da irgendwie sich nicht mehr so wohl gefühlt haben. Und dann dieser immense Druck, der dann herrscht. Deine Fans, dein Land steht total geschlossen hinter dir, aber die denken halt auch, du spielst mit dem Titel mit, weil du halt Messi hast, weil du halt irgendwie die ganzen Torjäger der ganzen europäischen Top-Ligen, die hast du in deinem Kader.
Also du hast ja die Finals angesprochen. Und das WM-Finale 2014 ist ein perfektes Beispiel dafür, wie die Perspektiven unterschiedlicher Fanlage, die komplette Bewertung von so einem Spiel, uneindeutig machen. Die Deutschen sagen, ja, wir hatten diese Höwertisch-Chance und dann kam das tolle Tor von Götze und Schweinsteiger war der Held schlechthin. Die Argentinier sagen, ey, hätte Neuer nicht vom Platz fliegen müssen. Wir hatten die riesen Chance von Messi in der, ich glaube, 47. oder 48. Minute oder sowas. Also man war ja auch sehr nah dran, möchte ich damit sagen. Also du hast jetzt gesagt, kein Tor erzieht in diesem Finalspielen, aber man war ja dreimal im Finale, zweimal im Elfmeterschießen verloren und dann dieses 2014er-Ding wurde auch wirklich, wenn man objektiv einen Schritt zurück tritt, sagen kannst, da hatte Argentinien sehr gute Möglichkeiten, das Ding auch zu gewinnen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich finde auch, das ist in der Diskussion, die ich heute noch führe, mit vielen Argentinien genau dieses Finale eben. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich habe Deutschland besser gesehen im Finale. Also ein bisschen, einen Ticken besser. Aber die besseren Chancen hatte ganz klar Argentinien. Das kann man gar nicht anders sehen. Und ich finde auch, ein Torpstürmer wie Iguain muss das Ding einfach machen.
Ja genau, das habe ich ja noch vergessen. Genau, Großköpft auf Iguain.
Ja, es ist unglaublich, dass du das nicht machst. Also wenn jetzt irgendwie ein 19-Jähriger, weißt du, die Chance hat und die versämmelt. Aber so ein gestandener Torhüter wie er. Und das ist ja, ich will mich nicht auf ihn einschießen. Das gilt ja auch für Kun Agüedo beispielsweise, der bei Manzi, die alles trifft, aber der in der Nationalmannschaft, also ist ein anderer Spieler. Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Jungs passiert, wenn die da in Ezei Simonas Aides einchecken am Flughafen und zurück sind, aber das sind nicht die gleichen treffsicheren Stürmer, weil ansonsten hätte Argentinien sicher den einen oder anderen Titel geholt. Auch wenn die defensiver anfällig ist, aber eigentlich mit diesem Offensivpotential musst du irgendwas holen oder zumindest Tore schießen und das machen die ja nicht. Das Problem ist, die spielen sich wenig Chancen raus und diese wenigen klaren Chancen, die sie dann haben, die machen sie auch nicht rein, außer Messi. Der liefert ja noch wenigstens. Aber so seine Kameraden, die haben alle irgendwie auch den Druck, wir sind ja Messi und spiele ich den beiden nicht besser doch wieder zu ihm. Und das macht irgendwie, ich glaube, das ist auch eine Frage des Selbstvertrauens in dem Moment, dass vielleicht als Torjäger, weiß ich nicht, so ein Iguain, der ansonsten so der Go-To-Guy ist oder er ist der, der die Tore schießt und in der Nationalmannschaft ist halt dieser Schatten von Messi so groß, dass du vielleicht ein bisschen zweifelst und denkst, ah, suche ich jetzt selbst einen Abschluss oder ja, oder wo ist eigentlich Leo, was macht der eigentlich, spiele ich ihn doch nochmal an und der macht das dann. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein riesiges Problem und ja, ich freue mich jetzt, die neue zusammengestellte Mannschaft, sind ganz viele Junge, ist Santiago Ascasi war auch dabei aus Stuttgart.
Und Icardi durfte auch wieder spielen.
Die haben getroffen, beide gestern, Icardi und Di Balla haben gestern beide getroffen.
Gegen Mexiko. Zwei zu mann.
Und war auch das erste Tor von Icardi. Und die Jungs sollen sich mal einspielen. Der Sohn von Simeone hat gespielt, Giovanni. Und das ist halt, ich finde, eine super Mannschaft, die die jetzt auf dem Platz haben. Und mit Taklia Fico auch ein toller Leader, der von Ajax Amsterdam. Da könnte was heranwachsen, ob das jetzt für die nächste WM reicht, sei jetzt mal dahingestellt, weil der Kader doch sehr jung ist aktuell. Ich hoffe nur, dass sie das Projekt durchziehen, aber bei der AFA weißt du halt auch nie, was passiert.
Also dem Argentinischen Fußballverband, genau.
Genau, die AFA ist von dort zum DFB. Und eine kleine Anekdote, die mir gerade einfällt, weil wir Iguain gesagt haben, sein Vater übrigens hat für beide Finalisten gespielt.
Oh, gibt es das, dass man sowohl bei River Plate als auch bei Boca gespielt hat?
Also gibt es einige, das passiert nicht häufig, aber es gibt doch einige. Und der Papa von Iguain gehört beispielsweise dazu. Maidana, der in der Innenverteidigung spielt, hat mit Boca sogar die Copa Libertadores in 2007 gewonnen. Und Battistuta, Canigia, beide. Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch Gatti kennst, einen Tormann.
Nee, sagt mir nichts.
Ruggieri ist ein anderer, Galeca, die haben auch für beide gespielt. Ja, Jorge Iguain, der Verteidiger war, der hat erst bei Boca gespielt und ist dann nach Frankreich gewechselt. Er wurde übrigens in Gonzalo geboren, deswegen hat er ja die französische Staatsbürgerschaft. Und danach ging es dann wieder zurück und dann hat er 4 Jahre bei River gespielt. Also er hat länger bei River gespielt, aber war bei beiden halt aktiv. Sein Sohn, der Gonzalo, war ja auch ein Torschütze in einem Superclassico. Also Pippita, sein Vater El Pippa und der kleine Pippita. Es gibt sehr viele Geschichten. Wir könnten jetzt noch stundenlang reden.
Wir könnten noch stundenlang reden, aber es soll ja beim Kurzpass bleiben. Und vor allem sollen ja die Hörerinnen und Hörer das hier noch hören, bevor sie sich dann rot im Kalender markieren. An diesem Samstag, dem 24. November, um 21 Uhr steigt das Rückspiel. Dann eben mit der Heimmannschaft River Plate und Boca Juniors wird dann zu Gast sein. Das Ganze wird auf der Zone übertragen. Das heißt, ihr habt auch die Möglichkeit, es live zu sehen, wenn euch das ein Abo bei der Zone wert ist. Und dann bin ich sehr gespannt. Ich bin total gehypte, ehrlich gesagt, Andreas. Ich werde leider wegen der Schlusskonferenzvorbereitung, wie immer, nur Bundesliga gucken können am Wochenende. Aber das ziehe ich mir noch mal im Real Life rein. Und dann zähle ich die zwei Gipfel. Mach es.
Übrigens, das könnte um 20 Uhr angepfiffen werden. Die sind sich da noch nicht so ganz sicher. 21 Uhr war gedacht. Aber die letzte Info aus Argentinien ist wahrscheinlich 20 Uhr.
Wie kann man sich da nicht sicher sein? Kannst du mir das noch kurz erklären?
Ja, da gibt es wegen Polizeiaufgebotensicherheitsvorkehrungen, also dieser Hintergrund. Sowieso hätte das Finale ja erst nächste Woche stattfinden sollen. Aber da ist ja der G20-Gipfel in Buenos Aires.
Ach seht ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, nicht nur in der Bundesliga geht es auch rauf und runter. Und man kann sich da so einige Male beschweren. Auch in Argentinien. Okay, also wir bleiben einfach am Samstag, am späten Nachmittag sollten alle so in der Hab-Acht-Stellung sein. Irgendwann wird dieses Finale angepfiffen. Und dann kann man sich das eben angucken. Man kann dir auch auf Twitter folgen, Andreas, als atf-fundegaipe werde ich natürlich verlinken. Und du warst jetzt viel zu bescheiden, um zu sagen, dass man auch etwas von dir sehen kann im Internet. Das wollen wir aber nicht verschweigen an der Stelle.
Du sprichst dann auf die Dokumentation an. Los Cedres Cedros de Quilmes wahrscheinlich. Ja, gerne. Also ich glaube für jemanden, der ein bisschen in den argentinischen Fußball eintauchen will, ist das eine schöne 30 Minuten, um das zu tun, über den ältesten Verein in Argentinien. Aus Quilmes, vielleicht hat der eine oder andere das Bier mal getrunken. Aus Quilmes, das ist so die Bierstadt. Deswegen heißt die Fanszene auch Cerdo Vecedos, das heißt übersetzt die Bierbrauer. Dementsprechend heißt das Fanlager Cerdo Vecedos und ist eine Mannschaft, die aktuell in der 2. Liga spielt, die damals aber noch in der 1. Liga waren, in dem Jahr, wo wir die Doku gemacht haben. Wir haben die 2-3 Monate begleitet, die Jungs, die Fans. Da sind sie auch abgestiegen. Das war in dem gleichen Jahr, wo River Plate auch abgestiegen ist. Erstmals in diesem Skandalabstieg. Wir hatten da irgendwie das Glück, mit der Barabra auf die ganzen Spiele zu fahren, mit denen abzuhängen. Wir haben einen sehr intensiven Einblick bekommen, was da so passiert. In den 30 Minuten allerdings war das Ziel, dass man diesen futboler Argentino aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln kennenlernen kann. Und sich im besten Fall mit einem, wir haben sieben verschiedene Gesprächspartner, mit einem von denen identifizieren kann. Das hat am Beispiel von Kilmes diese Passion, diese Leidenschaft, die so unglaublich intensiv gelebt wird in Argentinien, dass man das so ein bisschen verstehen kann.
Und das hat funktioniert, wenn ich mal da für mich sprechen darf. Sehr, sehr schöne Doku, auch mit Aufnahmen, wo man gleich versteht, auch ohne Hintergrundwissen dazu zu haben. Das ist nicht selbstverständlich, dass man bei den Ultras da, bei der Auswärtsfahrt im Bus mitfahren kann und das vor allem dann alles noch filmen darf. Da muss man ja nicht mal argentinische Maßstäbe anlegen der Fernkultur, sondern da reichen auch deutsche Maßstäbe der Fernkultur. Und zu sehen, da ist euch ein besonderer Einblick gelungen. Ich werde es verlinken und empfehle es allen Hörern und Hörern sehr. Dann danke dir, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast. Andreas Geipel, ad fan de Geip, bei Twitter. Andreas, sehr schön. Und mal gucken. Ich weiß jetzt immer, bei wem ich mich melden kann, wenn ich über was über den argentinischen Fußball sprechen möchte.
Ja, gerne. Das darfst du gerne machen. Ich wünsche dir auf jeden Fall, oder allen Hörern, die sich das Finale anschauen am Samstag, ihr werdet es nicht bereuen. Vielleicht ist es nicht das beste Fußballspiel, das man sich ansehen kann an dem Samstag. Aber es ist zu 100 Prozent das Intensivste, und da geht es richtig zur Sache. Und auf das kann man sich echt nur freuen. Rechtzeitig einschalten. Man muss auf jeden Fall sehen, wie die Mannschaften reinkommen, das Feuerwerk, wie die Fans abgehen. Am besten den Ton so laut, wie es geht. Die Nachbarn können mithören. Es wird ein unglaubliches Spiel. Wie gesagt, es ist zum ersten Mal, dass dieses Finale in dieser Form so stattfindet. Ich habe so viele Freunde, die Boca oder River Fans, und ich kriege das ja mit, wie die sich jetzt schon die ganze Zeit bombardieren mit irgendwelchen Nachrichten und so. Also es wird für mich ein Riesenspaß. Und ich hoffe für jeden anderen, der sich das anguckt auch.
Bessere Werbung hättest du nicht machen können. Andreas, vielen herzlichen Dank dir, vielen herzlichen Dank auch an euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und auch an alle, die uns finanziell unterstützen, unter rasen.de/unterstützenkönntihr das tun. Und dann bleiben wir weiter werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Außer wir machen mal Werbung für ein gutes Fußballspiel. Das soll dann aber auch erlaubt sein an dieser Stelle. Und mal gucken, ob dann dieses Spiel tatsächlich mithalten kann mit der Partie. Ja, was haben wir denn da in der Bundesliga? Harter Hoffnheim. Mal gucken. Bis zum nächsten Mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Macht's gut.